إنه لغز وهذا يضع
الكثير من العبء على عاتقنا جميعًا حيث
يبحث الجميع عن المعلومات
تمامًا كما نعتقد أنهم يعتقدون أن لدينا
إجابات للأسف لم نكن عبد الله
مع سمعنا من الحكومة التركية
التي لديها  قالوا إنهم
يعتقدون أن والدك دخل
إلى القنصلية وأنه تعرض للاختناق
لأنه قُتل بعد ذلك من قبل
الحكومة السعودية ، ونحن نفهم أنه
قُتل حتى الآن ، إنها غامضة
مثل القصة مثل تفاصيل ما
حدث بالضبط في الداخل  أنت تعرف كيف
يحكي كل من وسائل الإعلام قنوات التليفزيون على تويتر
قصة مختلفة ،
وبالنسبة لي أحاول تبسيط الأمر
قدر المستطاع حتى أنه مات
وأعتقد أنني كنت أعرف آخر
من رآه من أبناء والدك.
لقد رأيته قبل شهرين في تركيا ،
كيف حاله ، ثم كان سعيدًا ، نعم ، لقد
كانت فرصة جيدة جدًا
بالنسبة لي لرؤيته
ونحن نتسكع في اسطنبول ، لقد استمتعنا وأعتقد أنني كنت
محظوظًا حقًا لأنني حصلت على ذلك  لا  لحظة
معه ، كيف لم يكن الأمر دائمًا على
عائلتك على والدتك وأخواتك
، إنه أسود صعب ، ليس من السهل
خاصة في التدمير يصبح هذا كبيرًا ، إنه
ليس سهلاً ، إنه محير حتى
الطريقة التي نحزن بها ، إنه مربك بعض الشيء
لأنه  نحن نحزن في نفس الوقت
الذي ننظر فيه إلى وسائل الإعلام
والمعلومات المضللة كأن هناك الكثير من الصعود
والهبوط ، إنه ليس وضعًا طبيعيًا
كما لو أنه ليس قرصًا عاديًا على
الإطلاق ما نريده الآن هو
- أفضل  داخل
المدينة المنورة والعودة إليها مع شهادته لعائلته في
المملكة العربية السعودية في المملكة العربية السعودية ، نعم
تحدثت إلى أنني تحدثت عن ذلك
مع بعض السلطات وآمل فقط
أن يحدث ذلك قريبًا ولكن عليك
أن تجد شخصًا ما يحتاج إلى  اعثر على جسده
نعم أعتقد أن البحث مستمر
ومتفائل حقًا بشأن ذلك ، لكن
ما الذي تعلقه على آمالك وهو
تقليد إسلامي ليس فقط إسلاميًا
إنه قضية إنسانية أساسية
نحتاج فقط للتأكد من ذلك هنا  هو بعض
السلام حتى الآن قلت لا أصدق
أنه ميت ، أنا أعلم أنني أعني أنه
لم يغرق مرة أخرى معي عاطفياً
لقد مات بالتأكيد ولكن
العبء العاطفي الذي يأتي مع
اللغز هو في الحقيقة كبير جدًا
عندما  ذهبت إلى شقة والدك
هنا وفي الولايات المتحدة
تكتشف شيئًا جعلك
تدرك مدى أهمية
أحفاده بالنسبة له ، ما كان ذاهبًا
إلى الشقة التي ربما كانت أكثر
اللحظات العاطفية التي أحببتها في أفضل
الأيام هذه  الصورة خاصة أنها كانت
بجوار وسطه و Nexus bit
وأحفاده وهذا هو آخر
شيء نظر إليه قبل أن يذهب إلى الفراش هو
أن قول الصدمة nila غير متأكد
ولكنه أظهر لنا فقط أن رفيق جديد ليس
شيئًا جديدًا ولكنه وضع  التركيز على
جانبه اللطيف من محبة
عائلته وأحفاده وآخر شيء
كان هنا وكنت أحفاده
ولذا سيرى إنه مجرد شيء
ضخم ويمسوني شخصيًا
كأنها وكل رياح العائلة التي تعرفها
عنها ،
ما الأشياء التي من المحتمل أن تكون قد
قالها دائمًا بالحقيقة مثل الإنسان الأساسي
مجرد شخص جيد بهذه البساطة
وكان شجاعًا جدًا أنه كان دائمًا
موجودًا بالنسبة لي كان مثل موسيقى الروك-
نجم أند رول وجير كصحفي يعجبك
لأنك نظام ودائمًا ما
يدفع بأنه كان دائمًا نعم إنه شجاع ،
كان هناك أشخاص
يحاولون نوعًا ما خلق انطباع مختلف
عنه مزاعم إرث مختلفة
بأنه كان نوعًا ما  من
دعم الإخوان المسلمين ، لا
أعتقد ذلك ، لذا
يمكنك إلقاء الضوء على أنني كنت
أضايقه كثيرًا مثل آخر مرة التقيت
به في تركيا كنت أضايقه كما
فعلت ذلك على Twitter كما
يقولون  إخوانكم المسلمون ، أين
لحيتك مرهقة وهو يضحك
وقد حاول أن يخوض في التفاصيل أنا لست
مسلمًا وليس بسبب هذا ،
فهذه هوية غير مرجحة نعم وهي
مجرد تسميات أو مجرد أشخاص لا يؤدون
واجباتهم المدرسية بشكل صحيح ويقرأون.
مقالته تتراجع ، لذا من
السهل عليهم فقط لصق ملصق عليه
كأنك شيء
أنت متسخ أو هل يمكن أن تخبرنا
عن ذلك الاجتماع مع ولي
العهد والملك نعم  في ذلك الاجتماع
مع الملك في ولي العهد عندما
ذهبت إلى هناك مع عمي سال
، أكد الملك أن كل شخص معني
سيتم تقديمه إلى العدالة ولدي
إيمان بأن هذا سيحدث ، فأنت تضع
ثقتك في اللعبة نعم
حدث شيء سيء  قد
يكون الأمر كذلك ولكني آمل حقًا أنه مهما
حدث كان مجرد أنه لم يكن
مؤلمًا له أو شيء من هذا القبيل
أو كان سريعًا أو كان لديه موت سلمي
وهذا ما أتمناه لأنني لست
متأكدًا من أنني أقصد الانتظار فقط  الحقائق
التي تظهر لي إنها مجرد موت
أعلم أنه مات كل ما
أنتظره هو أن ينتهي التحقيق
حتى تظهر الحقائق كيف
تعتقد أن والدك يريد أن
يتذكره المرء كرجل معتدل
الذي حضر الحفلات مع الجميع
صادق صادق رجل أحب بلاده
وآمن بها كثيرًا وإمكاناتها
لم يكن جمال أبدًا معارضًا
عن النظام الملكي ، لقد كان يؤمن بالملكية أن هذا هو الشيء
الذي يحافظ على تماسك البلاد ،
وكان يؤمن بالتحول
الذي يمر به.  من خلال
وهذا كيف يجب أن نتذكره